well I was gonna relax today and someone
had to go and [ __ ] and Sonic the
Hedgehog's mouth so here I am oh my god
like this looks like a joke this is a
joke right a couple years ago Andre
Meadows and I did a video where I think
it's titled we ruin your childhood where
we come up with a bunch of bad ideas on
how to remake properties from your child
and turn them into movies the running
joke was in the mood for a new portal
and come to our world because that plot
device is stupid it's never really
worked out ever even the Smurfs knew to
stop me the last Smurfs movie and never
saw it but doesn't it take place in
their world not ours cuz they were like
yeah I guess didn't come into our world
that that's just dumb we're over it now
I thought Hollywood was over it but note
Sonic the Hedgehog and then he finds a
portal or however the hell it gets to
our world I like the song choice I like
the song they use gangster's paradise
great song from the 90s which is when
this movie should have been made if it
were in the 90s at least we could have
been like oh it's nineties crap Mario
movie was crap this is crap of course
it's crap this movie being made now just
looks like it was in some sort of Time
Vault when James Marcin was like I want
to be a big actor and Jim Carrey was a
big actor and now we're here Jim Carrey
is dr. Robotnik or dr. B's called dr.
egghead now or whatever Eggman egg
person that comes with a tab when he was
called Robotnik he's Jim Carrey he's Jim
Carrey playing Robotnik how Jim Carrey
played the Grinch are usually when I'm
talking about trailers I might have my
phone with me so I can watch the trailer
while I'm talking in between the cots
Billy oh when I'm talking about that
that's right I totally forgot I don't
have that pulled up on my phone I'm not
watching that trailer again I saw it
once all these thoughts are based on me
singing at once because I will not be
watching it a second time unless some
projectionists puts it on a movie and I
have no choice because I'm sitting there
who directed this piece of [ __ ] he
directed a short film in 2004 called go
for broke was that are those two
credentials was some executive out there
like uh-huh yeah yeah he directed a film
about Gophers of 2004 he's the perfect
guy to direct a film about a hedgehog
I feel like this video game movies back
to 20 years
why not just have it take place in the
Sonic the Hedgehog world have the
animals be able to talk they're being
captured by dr. egghead / Robotnik then
like hey Sonic's on
like I'm the only one who can maybe
tails is like and I'll go with you we
have like a buddy rodent movie but in
their world and like really fast and
running up cliff so it could be really
cool you don't need the army you know
they the military you don't need this
shitty m.bison from the shitty Street
Fighter movie yeah the shitty one and
please use that as perspective I'm
saying the street fighter Van Damme
movie I like it I enjoy that shitty
movie the person who likes that movies
saying this looks like a [ __ ] bus
fire but they had the beam me to be like
the ring sound effect otherwise known as
the sound effect of cash registers at
gas stations I don't know why they have
the sound effect but they all do they
yeah don't give me that nostalgic sound
effect we know this is gonna be crap
yeah what if it's good right
what if it's good my only conclusion if
it's good will be and then I found a
portal and went into a parallel universe
I didn't know existed I didn't even know
I step through a portal I just didn't
know they were gonna use Andres video
where we joke about finding a portal as
a how-to so the trailer for Sonic the
Hedgehog have you seen it if you haven't
don't save yourselves the time but if
you have seen it and you went through it
bless you a prayer for those lost but if
you've seen the trailer whatever you
thought about the trailer comment below
let me know and as always if you liked
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]